hey guys and welcome to another episode
of Rissa fury I'm Kelsey kinetic and
today I am joined by the amazing and
hilarious Kyle Dunnigan thank you whoo
not a big applause you slid into my DMS
yeah well casually and drop the news
that you were like a foosball champion
in college yeah well I won one foosball
contest in college okay there's five
people in it but I feel like that gives
me some played another champion no and I
love that you're like for sure a
champion yeah and you felt like that was
enough to come come to this - that is
enough okay and when I came here before
they give me a tour of this facility I
saw this and I said I want to do that
and then no one contacted me that's why
to go directly to the source well now
here we are Here I am and I'm feeling do
you regret doing this do you I'm so far
we haven't even started yeah no I'm
definitely less confident than I was on
Instagram but I feel like if I can do
two goals that will I'll feel like I can
leave with my head up so we're just
that's like where you're aiming for is
two goals not not the wind but just if
you can get to you'll be happy is you're
a champion right Wow yeah those are
really fancy looking look this fire can
you feel feel how that plastic oh
my god
yeah no it's bad it's really bad
we're gonna drop it in so this is how
actually now even though they still make
the tables with the holes here sometimes
you actually start the ball on your five
bar and you ask the opponent may I
continue
may I go are you say ready and then I
say ready and then you're supposed to
touch two men like to the Cote men wait
a second and then move the ball forward
okay so it prevents people from just
like right okay so okay are you ready I
am ready sir
oh all right all right so far a lot of
action okay everyone relax everyone
we're just going down haven't touched
anything yet okay how do you feel so far
excuse me one second all right here we
go
do I get to go again how would I touched
it
I wish even agon is just like casually
peed on that plan okay well I don't feel
like I even played yet all right here we
go it's fast okay there we go ready
there you go can you you've got all
right here we go all right
zero this is not fun for you so far here
it is though I mean there's two levels
of fun there's fun where it's fun to
like play with somebody who's good and
it's also fun to just beat somebody
mercilessly yeah that's true so far we
have a merciless they see a candy I know
what's up ooh I didn't get a warm-up at
all just disclaimer fur wait a minute is
it 3-0 damn here we go I have to also
say so this is my first time meeting you
today and it's so funny to just talk to
you because of all I ever see you in is
character
Russians and your face swaps and all
that so like I was like oh
I've never heard your house is very
brony and like a robot it's like you
either as Craig or Trump or Caitlyn
Jenner and yeah I should have come in as
a character I mean you're definitely I
mean these guys haven't touched it yet
the scorer's sorry I just wanted to give
you a little oh come on I really made
that you have over half a million
Instagram followers like that is insane
did that when did that start to really
take off did something go viral or did
you just already have like a big
following that's so hard to go talk yeah
oh no what is sex come on okay Joe Rogan
talked about it in Tom Segura talked
about it and then Bill burr talked about
it oh my god
yeah so where was it but like what was
your following before that happened it
was like 20,000 are you serious yeah
it's pretty quick there's an Adam
Corolla doing impressions
I know it's over half a million have you
ever had the people that you like the
celebrities you impersonate I like you
know I like about this is you've
destroyed me but you're building my
confidence like but your Instagram is
good helps we're gonna play the second
round now and I feel like you will
definitely get it there because I'm
gonna have to do some weird good so
can I spin this yes you can spin this
okay you ready what's going to you yes
it did where the dog treats for you'll
see okay am i eating a dog train okay
may or may not be in and our train
wait you're like picking well I just for
yeah for okay
so you have four I have two okay so you
have to play in a different character
each point so like you have to play as
Craig one point and Caitlyn Jenner
during a point and so all like I'll tell
you which one to do okay all right cool
of that that's cool okay what are you
doing maybe Craig will be better at
first ball than you anybody I didn't do
anything
I literally maybe Trump's are really
gonna go scored on terrific all right
what are you doing so we're gonna do
something we have not done before I have
no idea how this is gonna go well I have
to play like backward with my back to
the table
alright that okay have you ever done
this no I've never even practiced glad
you'll be terrible I'm gonna
myself by the end of this this is so
uncomfortable Jesus Christ here you can
start with this doesn't seem fair at all
do right let's see how it goes there we
go okay
so you have to play this first point as
your character Craig it's Gregor
originally from Reno 9 1 1 division
doing that character I just always did
it I don't remember doing it yeah that's
my mother would always do characters
with me for some weird reason I know
she's really regretting that based on
those videos yeah she's in them I know I
know I love them are those real I do you
actually surprised her and brain just
say this and she's she's not good with
lines you need to have her improv
because she's she gets nervous okay I
actually was filming something wait to
go back and redo it and she couldn't do
a specific line without feeling don't do
that's Craig is very high school Craig
no Craig she's right
she's amazing I remember as a kid being
thinking like this lady keeps doing
these for hours we would do this
really he's a kid usually annoy your
parents I was like that's enough lady
okay was a character and now Craig was
on Reno nine one one and now yep and now
here we are playing foosball yeah all
right guys this is impossible this is
impossible
here comes the Craig me oh I hate our
producer right now oh that's nice a shot
I'd go backwards girl this is so
disorienting I feel like I'm drunk
nobody's doing a good tactic everyone's
pretty care about death actually I know
it seems so like not but okay um okay
play as Caitlyn Jenner all right baby
here we go
let's get these men nice gross men
passionate about hair just show me the
balls on the cable right okay they yeah
actually guys catching it again yeah
baby here I come I'm losing
this feels horrible damn it here we go I
kind of hope that somebody is watching
this for the first time right now and
just thinks I'm like really really
deeply like captain does not understand
oh I keep losing my characters baby
Caitlyn do you think oh okay King you oh
my God my neck Chris can you bring Kim
Kardashian oh yeah she's available
oh oh my god you're kicking my ass
okay Trump I want to play ball again
this is so terrific leg against a woman
okay okay you're halfway to your goal of
CEO points it doesn't count you're
backwards okay Cup so terrific sub
terrific passes hair back to fourth okay
Oh booze balls usually played by losers
okay
bunch of losers boss know you're
actually getting close to my score all
right the fact that you scored through a
backwards is pretty much retire I think
so um can you play as Craig again all
right it's no one like Trump you guys
are back to me okay a lot of action here
Craig you're retired against me
right now you're backwards yeah but this
may be the first time that anybody beats
me in the second round
wait do you get the ball I do get the
ball thank you gonna cheat it Craig the
cheater okay one more so Craig um
what's been happening in your life
lately how's your mom mom it's pretty
awesome yeah my best friends do a lot
stuff together makes me peanut butter
sandwiches nice you live at home right
oh yeah it's the best Jimmy
how old are you distract me you better
stay that's all I got I'm not sure how
old am I think I'm Mike six I might be
40th Lex I'm not sure that's what sex
are for to sexy yes that was amazing
though backwards
thank you oh my god my neck is destroyed
this is winner takes all in the third
round even though I've beat you the
first two games if you beat me in the
third game you're technically the
champion all right good okay so we're
gonna play two ball so that means we
each start with the ball and you have to
score both of them in order to get a
point okay so if I score why don't you
scrub one it's just a wash so we'll go
to five if you lose these are your
punishment choices since they win
exactly I mean when you lose you can
either do a face swap video as one of
your characters as Craig's forever
talking about how I kicked your ass at
football or you can eat a dog treat Wow
can you tell what's in the dog treat
their Milk Bone I'm actually a little
curious with a dog treat what do you
just want to eat it just I'm serious I
feel like Craig would just eat the dog
treat rhaggy
amen to that what do I get if I won
which I mean we don't even bother Oh
kind of like a time
got it okay cool cool so you have an
injury by the way that I've been playing
with oh that I get it now that makes so
much sense for what's happening yeah it
seemed like that would be the problem it
almost went through all the layers of
skin all right here we go
ready one two three
oh you do have a pretty good
defensive stance I will say that
oh that's the illegal don't do that I'm
realizing technically you you beat your
goal because you wanted to get two
points on me and you got a three you
know but that wasn't I want to do it
legally not you know you've reversed oh
good save so your D is honestly better
than I feel like I've gotten kind of
used to people like not knowing how you
feel about this you like to ball I feel
like I'm getting a little more practice
all right ready one two three
Oh first one so quick and the second one
come I gonna wash this one there's a lot
of rush to losing so bad kind of drag
here's like oh my god am I even here all
right
two three why does that happen you light
it up know you're doing that you're
literally trying to get it in on the
first thing oh yeah I thought we were
just having fun now I have to make this
so it's a wash all right I wanted that
one bad can smell it in the air one so
hard for you during the show cuz I want
to just have like a fun conversation
with you and I physically don't know
it's so hard to talk while you play all
right it's gonna be entertaining I'm
really sorry I'm just really into this
no don't be I mean I feel bad as the
host hey ready one two three
[Applause]
okay all right this may be it
this is it you ready yeah
oh really wanted that one I'm good
look I know your congratulations you're
ready with it you were like if I did
this for another 400 hours
I could score a point don't feel bad
there are pictures of me playing when I
was like 2 years old standing on a stool
like it's do you want to bring a pro
into this are you now ready to hey I
want a real challenge on the show I
think so I would think yeah oh and you
were saying that as if you were about to
like become you're gonna turn around and
be a new character foosball guy we have
to eat a dog treat that's Craig oh my
god oh my god Craig's gonna eat a dog
treat this is it's healthy right I don't
know all right guys tonight just dog
trait right here it's probably got some
pretty good stuff in it cuz cuz dogs did
it a scrunchy it's got some pretty good
flavors
what does it taste like Craig it is sort
of like a crackers if it was in a drawer
for a few weeks
it's getting pretty dry in my mouth I
don't want to do this anymore okay
I do you want like some milk or
something yeah I'll taste them not get
it pretty often it's very dry yeah this
sound that is coming from your mouth as
you chew is so upsetting
oh my god
oh my god it sounds like there's cement
in your mouth
it's not that bad is Evan grossed out
that I hate a dog treat
you're a champ I probably should
look at the ingredients oh they smell so
bad they smelled like straight-up dog
treats I can't believe you just so like
casually ate that I think you are Kraig
I think it's legit
ingredients in that I might want to spit
it out what's in that Oh God oh is it
like animals now
well first ingredient is ground whole
wheat so this kit not bad wheat flour
meat and bone meal the rest come over
here thank you so much
I mean you chose that over doing the
face swap video I kind of camp it I
guess you guys set this up a hill for
sure to a face swap video oh I was
saying you could do one or the other I
think what got to me is my whole life I
would just been like what are its like
and this is my chance like I regret no I
mean I'm so glad we could provide that
lifelong opportunity for you know I wish
you hadn't but like I thought the
viewers thank you I'm sure you're
welcome so Kyle let people know where
they can find you like what they should
follow all that stuff um you find a
milk-bone calm and Instagram Kyle
Dunnigan one on Instagram and Kyle done
in comedy dot-com on the Internet
perfect if you don't follow him on
Instagram you're idiot his
videos are so funny it's insane there's
a reason he's over half a million
followers like that's it just blows my
mind thank you you guys can follow me on
instagram at Kelsey cook comedy my
website is Kelsey cook calm and make
sure to subscribe to the all things
comedy YouTube channel and watch the
other wrist of fury episodes we'll see
you guys next time
never thought I'd be eating no phone
right but I did
[Music]
you